I'm adding more language I'm trying to
do this sort of like slowly rather than
kind of like some sometimes I've been
guilty in a part of teaching like this
is a lesson it's all about words and
notation you don't learn how to do
anything you just learn what things are
called I have tried to avoid that so I'm
sort of gradually added here new bits of
language as they become relevant okay so
definite integrals definitely are what
you've been dealing with so far when
you've got a function you want to find
the area beneath it and you want to find
it between Betsy killer boundaries the
upper and lower bounds okay this is
called a definite integral now of course
that begs the question well what other
kind of integral art is there and we
will get to that in a minute well not in
a minute we'll get to that in a future
lesson but for now all of us you know is
where you see boundaries when there are
numbers here and here it's like okay I
want you to start here and stop there
there's a definite beginning and end
okay and there is also a definite number
at the end this is actually equal to
just like you know five or 18 or 2 pi or
something like that okay that's what we
mean by a definite interval okay so
that's what these are now we have a
series of things that we can notice
about definite integrals based on the
fact that it's a valid like they try to
solve the problem area right now you've
already noticed the first couple and I'm
just going to rehearse them for you just
you have all in one place based on
whether the function you're integrating
is all or even okay so you remember so
if f is on okay you can simply say if
you're not interested from a boundary
that's negative to the same value as
positive so negative a
a dead of course because those two areas
are going to exactly cancel out you're
just going to get 0 okay and
correspondingly if you have an even
function and you want to integrate that
you don't have to consider this as two
separate areas you consider it as double
the same area right so i would say
negative a 2a equals double zero today
because you just take it right down the
middle that axis of symmetry okay so
that's pretty simple we call this you
know there are two symmetric identities
there that's what I'm missing even's but
there's a whole bunch of other ones that
just come out of the definition that
definite inter was tell you about area
for instance okay so here's one two
here's the three suppose i say to you i
want a definite integral but i'm like
upper and lower bounds to be the same
number okay hmm if i integrate over an
interval which has no width right like
it's from a to a doesn't go anywhere
then that tells you the area has to be 0
right like you're not actually going
anywhere so that's a simple property of
a definition we go from here to here and
it's fairly easy to see why right like
it's defined by the primitive so you go
F of a takeaway ff8 because you've got
the same boundaries so that's why you
get zero tipple stuff right another one
again thinking about these boundaries
right if instead of going from a small
value to a big down a small a
suppose I go in reverse Riley going from
A to B I go from B to a now that's kind
of weird like why would you even do that
but if we have a look just like idea
here we've had a matt panter you can see
what the geometric meeting is okay if
I'm going in Reverse a to be but from B
to a let's just see what happens I'm
going to evaluate the primitive I
evaluated at the upper bound first and
then I evaluate an upper lower bound
right now how does this relate to all of
the definite integrals that you've seen
before like what is the definition of
this it's this one take away this one
what's the difference yeah it's this is
exactly this but negative okay so this
is negative open brackets every way hey
those primitives there so essentially
what we've done is we've got that
original regular definite integral but
we have the opposite we have the
negative of that and what does that mean
okay we'll remember I tried to explain
that drew geez are about change at an
instant and integrals are about a sum
total change and total change how much
have you change from here to here well
this is kind of like going backwards in
time right it's like well rather than
starting here and then going forward to
a few hours right imagine going
backwards well the effect will be I'll
be you know reverse where I started from
ok so the Advocate tells you that feels
ok two more or three more the next two
are about dividing up these upper and
lower bounds we call this the interval
over which we integrate ok so I'm
integrating for example from a to be
here or be day or a to a that interval
can be divided up ok so for instance
here's my arm 1 2 3 4 5th one if I have
an integral from A to B I can pick any
value between a and B in the middle if
you like so I'll call it m
and I can say well I'll do the first
chunk right integrate that little bit
and then I'll just do the next chunk
right so from A to M and then from M to
the end which is being right now what
this corresponds to is when you think
about just as composite areas it's a
simple idea this is one kind of integral
you need to know how to separate out the
second client is where you actually have
rather than you want to divide the
interval if you want you to divide up at
the integrand okay so if you have an
integrand that's made up of multiple
functions right so maybe we'll call them
fng ok because integrating works just
like differentiating right except in
Reverse because if you differentiate two
things together it's the same as
differentiator than one at a time you
can do exactly the same thing with
integration so I can say and a bit of
that function is going to be added to a
to b of this function ok hey you
remember I told you little while ago
when we were doing graphing we did
addition of ordnance sorry i'll finish
quickly right edition of ordnance it's
really simple right you just say ok I've
got one graph and then I've got you know
I'm not a graph and then you add those
values together and you get something
something else as a what we're going to
do something else as a result ok now
simply thinking about all of these
values here right like this is how you
do say this value plus this value this
value this value the ordinates these are
the ordinance to see that it's those
heights of those rectangles that you're
adding up ok so that's a simple one one
last properties sixth one in some ways
the most obvious but it's a bit strange
this definite integral right
do you notice that when I go back to
this definition the exes they all
disappear because they all get
substituted for AIDS and beat actual
numbers right so the exes don't really
matter right they're going to get
substituted for some numbers once I go
through the process so therefore I don't
have to call it X I can call it say you
right because that letter it's just
sitting there for a moment a pro normal
that sits there until I substitute
another room I can call it I don't know
how about tea or another common one
might be feet up right I can integrate
with respect to any variable I like now
this is actually even though it seems
very simple right because it just stands
out of this it's a crucial idea because
it now divorces not deserve important it
starts to help you see integration is
not just about wimps if we want to do
integration could be about Heights it
could be changes in an angle it could be
changes in time could be anything right
now this idea is so important that it
gets its own name this x y UT theta
because it's a variable that just
vanishes away it's just there for a
second it gets cold the dummy variable
it's not really there it's just standing
in okay it's a temporary placeholder
until I can actually put numbers in
there okay and that's that's the
unshackle integration from just finding
out rectangles your hands